... into all white suburbs. By moving
North and by concerning itself with
equality in housing and employment,
the Civil Rights Movement began to
encounter increased resistance,
the so-called white backlash.
During these marches, King and other demonstrators
were struck by bricks and bottles. "Oh I've been
hit so many times, I'm immune to it." "How
do you feel about this reception?" "Well
this is a terrible thing, I've been in many
demonstrations all across the South but I can
say that I have never seen even in Mississippi
and Alabama mobs as hostile and as hate-filled
as I've seen in Chicago." "But the march
will go on anyway?" "Oh very definitely,
we can't stop the march, we'll be going on
in a few minutes." "Do you feel you are in a
closed society, Dr. King, here in the southwest
side of Chicago?" "Oh yes, this is definitely a
closed society, but we're gonna make it an
open society and we feel that we have to do
it this way to bring the evil out into the
open so that this community will be forced
to deal with it." "And so the backlash.."